[Musique]
nos téléphones intelligents sont ils
vraiment exigent ils sont très utiles
sont indispensables de notre quotidien
ils sont bien capables de reconnaître
notre voix la plupart du temps mais sont
ils capables de reconnaître nos émotions
si nos téléphones étaient véritablement
un dirigeant serait capable de détecter
qu'on est par exemple stressé lorsqu'on
attend un texto important mais que notre
batterie est presque à plat si nos
tablettes étaient réellement
intelligente elle serait capable de
détecter
notre frustration lorsque la fonction
d'autocorrection nous fait dire des
choses qu'on veut vraiment dire sinon
monte était réellement exigeantes serait
capable de détecter que nos émotions
prennent le dessus et nous empêcher de
faire des achats impulsifs et c'était
possible saviez vous que nous les
humains nous générons l'équivalent d'une
encyclopédie britannique d'émotion à
chacun en d'autres termes nos réactions
physiologiques génère l'équivalent d'un
million pages de texte alors soit 1
gigaoctet de l'heure c'est l'équivalent
d'un bon documentaire en hd moi je suis
chercheur j'ai un laboratoire et j'ai
accès à une variété de capteurs qui
permettent d'enregistrer en temps réel
l'émotion d'humains d'utilisateurs en
interaction avec des technologies toutes
sortes des téléphones des tablettes des
ordinateurs ma passion trouver des
manières d'être capable de prendre en
compte l'émotion par la conception des
produits et services afin de créer des
expériences qui vont inciter les gens à
lui à les utiliser et à l'airé
utilisé en d'autres termes ce que je
fais dans la vie comme travaux c'est
qu'on tente de développer des nouvelles
manières d'évaluer l'expérience
utilisateur l'expérience réellement
vécue par les gens lorsqu ils
interagissent avec des technologies dans
le but d'être capable d'utiliser cette
émotion éventuellement pour rendre nos
appareils peut-être un peu plus
intelligent avant de vous expliquer
comment qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec
cette masse de données absolument ce
trône et mick qu'on peut collecter sur
vos émotions lorsque vous êtes en
interaction avec la technologie
laissez moi vous expliquer comment
aujourd'hui on est en mesure de
d'évaluer l'expérience utilisateur pour
ce faire laissez moi vous présenter un
professionnel en expérience utilisateur
aujourd'hui il vient de terminer la
conception d'un nouveau site web et il
va demander un utilisateur de l'essayer
pour la première fois les affaires vont
naviguer pendant quelques instants sur
le site web pour se faire une impression
et au bout de quelques minutes
le professionnel va demander à
l'utilisateur qu'est ce que tu en penses
est ce que tu peux évaluer sur une
échelle de 1 à 5
la facilité d'utilisation disons que
l'utilisateur répond trois sur cinq
qu'est ce que ça veut dire clairement
l'expérience est pas optimal quelque
chose qui cloche mais quoi exactement
peut-être que l'utilisateur fait une
moyenne
peut-être que c'est le début et facile à
la fin peut-être que l'utilisateur veut
pas nous dire franchement ce qu'ils en
pensent peut-être en réalité pense que
c'est un lac a consciemment n'est pas
capable rétrospectivement de revenir et
de comprendre ce que contribuer à
dégrader son expérience dans le fond il
ya rien de tout ça qui permet aux
professionnels de l'expérience
utilisateur de répondre à la vraie
question à quel moment
l'expérience n'est pas optimale
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait changer pour
rendre l'expérience plus facile et plus
agréable pour l'utilisateur
dans le fond les manière plus classique
d'évaluer l'expérience
utilisateurs ce que ça fait c'est que ça
prend pour acquis que l'utilisateur
c'est comme une boîte noire
on essaie de comprendre ce qui se passe
dans les bois mais on s'est vraiment
jamais ce qui se passe dans la boîte
moi ma passion mes travaux je vise à
voir à travers la boîte sans la briser
sans nous en ouvrir sans la briser
mais aussi de comprendre automatiquement
ce que vivent les utilisateurs au niveau
émotionnel et cognitif et bien ce sont
les avancées en technologie
d'acquisition de traitement de signaux
mêmes d'intelligence artificielle qui
pave la voie à notre capacité
d'exploiter ce gisement de mega données
humaines que vous générez en interaction
avec des technologies avec les
techniques statistiques approprié il
possible de pouvoir prédire avec une
bonne fiabilité l'émotion vécue par des
utilisateurs au moment même où elle se
manifeste
laissez moi vous donner un exemple
prenons les émotions faciale mais il est
possible de prédire l'émotion d'un
humain en mesurant la contraction de
certains muscles et la littérature dans
ce domaine là lens remonte jusqu'à
darwin par exemple je vais cinq filles
s'il met de la littérature des
recherches qui ont démontré que la
contraction du muscle du front thalys et
du corrupteur sont typiquement ceci a
des émotions de surprise tandis que la
contraction du zygomatique explique mme
ans assise à des émotions de plaisir
traditionnellement pour est capable de
mesurer précisément la contraction de
ses muscles on avait besoin placer des
capteurs partout dans le visage de
l'utilisateur
donc c'était clairement intrusif et ça
brise l authenticité de l'interaction
entre l'humain et l'appareil moi dans
mes recherches je compte se contente de
faim c'est capable de mesurer
automatiquement ces émotions là sans
interférer avec la nature très haut
antic de l'interaction mais aujourd'hui
avec avec une simple webcam et avec un
logiciel spécialisé est possible de
pouvoir mesurer automatiquement sans
capteur l'émotion vécue par un
utilisateur de manière très précise
prenons l'exemple de notre utilisateur
sur notre site web
et bien ce qu'on est capable de voir s
il sait exactement à 17 secondes après
le début de navigation claire 20
l'utilisateur a eu un moment de plaisir
il ya quelque chose qui se passe que
peut-être trouvé ce qu'ils cherchaient
sur le site web
mais quelques instants plus tard à
exactement trente deux secondes quelque
chose qui cloche
on détecte un des plaisait évident et
bien si on déteste cette émotion
négative la auprès d'un grand nombre
d'utilisateurs lors de nos expériences
mais on commence à voir un élément de
réponse à la question à quel moment
l'interaction des peuples meurent mais
juste dans l'exemple ici on vient de
générer le mas trône avec de données il
est très difficile en réalité pour un
concepteur d'être capable d'utiliser ces
technologies là pour l'aider à prendre
des décisions de design
par exemple moi dans mes travaux
lorsqu'on fait l'expérience avec une
vingtaine de participants
on peut accumuler de 30 à 50 gigaoctets
de données pour une seule expérience
rappelez-vous le c'est 30 à 50 ans clope
et 10 britannica c'est l'équivalent
d'une semi-remorque d'émotions depuis
cinq ans avec mes collaborateurs on a
mesuré l'expérience émotionnelle de
milliers d'utilisateurs en interaction
avec la technologie et on a accumulé le
plusieurs dizaines de thé rabeats de
données d'émotions humaines
de quoi remplir la bibliothèque du
congrès américain dans ce qui au pdi
émotionnel c'est énormément de données
c'est trop volumineux pour permettre à
des designers des concepteurs d'utiliser
cette donnée pourrait capable de prendre
des décisions de désert moi je travaille
les concepteurs à chaque jour et ils ont
besoin de réponses maintenant pas après
six mois d'analysé de mega données dont
4000 collaborateurs ce qu'on a développé
ses des manières
de représenter les motions en fonction
du regard d'un utilisateur à l'écran
donc on a breveté récemment une
technologie qui permet de le faire et
pour voulu illustrer je vais vous
présenter cette magnifique frittata
méditerranéenne je vais vous demander de
prendre quelques instants pour visionner
la page et vous imaginez en train de
préparer ce magnifique repas ce soir à
la maison donc dans notre laboratoire
on a accès à des équipements que se
nomme des kilomètres en 15 km ça
permette d'enregistrer avec grande
précision le regard d'un utilisateur
dans son interaction avec avec une
interface le km permet de produire des
analyses comme celle ci ça permet de
produire une carte de chaleur
attentionnel le diagramme que vous voyez
ici représente par exemple en rouge
l'endroit qui a été le plus regardé dans
les trains par le groupe d'utilisateurs
qui a consulté la page
donc ce qu on pourrait conclure par
exemple ici c'est que les gens ont passé
petain sur l'immense l'image du plats
préparés et ont concentré leur attention
surtout sur les instructions du club
après paris ça fait du sens
le concepteur pourrait utiliser les
résultats cette analyse et conclure
qu'il faudrait mettre plus d'emphase sur
les instructions et peut-être réduire
l'image par contre lorsqu'on croise
l'information attentionnel et émotionnel
c'est une toute autre histoire qui qui
se racontent ce que vous voyez ici ce
qu'on a développée que mes
collaborateurs c'est une carte de
chaleur émotionnelle ce que ça fournit à
l'écran ce que vous voyez est
essentiellement c'est la source d
émotion au moment du regard des
individus et l'histoire est complètement
différente
on constate que la photo et génère un
plaisir évident dans la page alors que
les instructions génère un fort du
plaisir
dans le fond là ce qui est arrivé les
gens sont tendus sur la page ont vu la
belle image sont dit on a vraiment l'air
bon on continue à lire les instructions
vie où ça va être difficile à préparer
donc vous voyez à quel point c'est
important de prendre en compte les
émotions dans la conception
parce que si on ne prend pas en compte
les émotions on peut vraiment
véritablement faire une erreur de design
mais il n'ya pas que les mentions dans
l'expérience utilisateur il ya également
la commission par exemple la charge
mentale l'effort cultive que vous devez
mettre pour interagir avec une
technologie
ça joue un grand rôle dans votre
capacité de trouver une technologie
faciles à étudier
moi j'ai dans mon laboratoire toute une
gamme de technologies qui permettent de
mesurer une grande précision
l'activité électrique de votre cerveau
pour être capable de mesurer cette
charge mentale mais disons que c'est un
peu encombrant existe d'autres
indicateurs qu'on peut utiliser pour est
capable nous informer la charge mentale
de l'utilisateur et le d'entre elles
c'est la dilatation de la peep et je
vous explique comment ça fonctionne
essentiellement c'est que je simplifie
s'il met plus la pupille dilatée plus la
charge mentale d'une personne est
susceptible d'augmenter
si la luminosité constante qu'on va
faire une expérience ici ensemble on va
faire du calcul mental
vous allez regarder dans les yeux de
votre voisin vous allez plus précisément
regarder ça pue pays et pour ceux qui
ont dans le cours de biologie 101 date
de quelques années que la qpc le petit
sac noir que vous avez au centre-ville
donc je vous demande regardez bien votre
voisin regardez le bien dans les yeux on
faire du calcul mental c'est une
excellente façon de faire connaissance
d'ailleurs
combien font deux fois trois bons très
facile on s'entend combien font 14 x 17
14 x 17
est-ce que vous avez vu la pupille
dilatée à moins d'avoir einstein à côté
de vous la pupille dilatée donc ce que
vous avez ici c'est évidemment une
information très utile dans la
conception des produits
on est capable de mesurer de manière
assez peu intrusive la charge mentale
d'une personne et si on avait à notre
disposition et de kilomètres on aurait
pu prendre trois cents photos en une
seconde et on aurait eu une mesure très
précise de votre villa tation deux pays
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec ça mais
avec mes collaborateurs ce qu'on a
développés c'est une manière de
représenter le cocktail d'émotions et
conditions vécues par des utilisateurs
dans le but d'être capable de comparer
ensemble des produits ou des prototypes
et pour vous illustrer je vous présenter
des résultats d'un récent un projet
qu'on a mené pour mesurer l'expérience
utilisateur de jeunes apprenant qu
utilisent des applications sur tablette
pour apprendre les mathématiques c'est
important l'expérience de l'apprenant
c'est probablement un facteur très
important dans la persistance colère
d'être capable d'avoir une expérience
optimale dans l'apprentissage et bien ce
qu'on a fait ici c'est qu'on a comparé
deux applications avec exactement le
même niveau de complexité mathématiques
donc c'est la même complexité mais deux
applications différentes vous allez voir
à quel point l'expérience vécue entre
ces deux applications est complètement
différente donc pour ce faire je vais
présenter un graphique d'abord vous avez
lax émotionnel donc à votre âme à gauche
vous avez le déplaisir et à droite vous
avez le plaisait dans l'autre axe l'axé
vertical
vous avez la commission donc en bas vous
avez la faible charge mentale et en os
une forte chargement
al essentiellement les ondes optimale de
développement développé une application
qui serait facile à utiliser et créerait
une émotion positive devrait
probablement compatible avec la
persistance kohler donc comparé en ont
deux applications donc d'abord
l'application 1
et si ce que vous voyez c'est un nuage
de points qui représente l'expérience
instantané à chaque 200000 seconde vécue
par tous les utilisateurs qui ont
participé à l'étude dont vous avez
vraiment une expérience ici qui est
difficile et nettement les présents
voyons voir l'application b une
expérience totalement différente
ce que vous avez ici c'est objectivement
l'application bl est plus facile à
utiliser et en plus elle génère un
expérience qui est positive qui amènera
l'enfant sûrement avoir utilisé et
réutilisées l'application dans son
apprentissage donc une manière aussi de
pouvoir comparer différents prototypes
et de prendre des décisions de
conception où on est capable réellement
objectivement de comparer l'expérience
vécue entre les utilisateurs
est ce qu'on pourrait faire ça
maintenant en temps réel et dans la vie
de tous les jours ça pourrait vraiment
changé notre vie en société notre façon
d'apprendre une façon de travailler mais
c'est ce qui est en train de se produire
par exemple et les manufacturiers qui
ont récemment commercialisé un
ordinateur dans laquelle il ya une km
embarqué dans l'écrin le bull c'est pour
permettre à des gens handicapés de
pouvoir interroger uniquement avec leurs
regards avec l'ordinateur
les logiciels qu'on utilise nous en
recherche pour la détection des émotions
mais ils deviennent disponibles men
commercialement sur le marché mais c'est
vraiment pas tout on va voir apparaître
dans les prochaines années des
interfaces dite auto adaptative capable
de reconnaître l'émotion et la
commission des utilisateurs
éventuellement de capable de s'adapter à
votre état images les imaginer des
fournisseurs de contenu média capable de
vous fournir des suggestions adapté à
votre humeur du moment
imaginez imaginer des voitures autonomes
capables d'utiliser l'émotion du
conducteur comme avertissement de
sécurité
imaginez un enseignant capable de
détecter automatiquement la charge
mentale d'apprenants et d'ajuster son
enseignement en fonction de cette
information
et bien moi je pense que c'est vos
émotions qui vont rendre vos appareils
intelligents vraiment intelligent merci
[Applaudissements]